this video is brought to you by news
voice
the news is broken almost all of the us
media is owned by just a handful of big
corporations fake news is obviously a
huge problem as well and finding
something unbiased can be hard news
voice is revolutionizing the news
landscape it's an app that gives you a
personalized news feed by aggregating
major news sites as well as
international and independent media
giving some much needed balance each
news story shows multiple sources which
are all tagged with their bias and
perspective the news affects almost
everything in our lives what we hear and
what we read shapes which people we
trust what we eat what we buy how we
vote and even how we think news voice is
created by its readers as you can upvote
stories that you find interesting so
more people will see them it's
essentially a democratized platform for
news plus it saves you time you get all
the news and all the sources in one app
so that you can be better informed and
it's totally free so get started with
news voice today for free through the
link below it's available on both google
play and the apple app store and now
that's out of the way let's get into
today's video
[Music]
thailand is a country capable of
attracting buddhist monks adventure
seeking tourists as well as the types
you might find in the hangover part 2
all at the same time there are many
reasons why we have all heard stories of
incredible parties in bangkok and not in
other places like brunei or malaysia
reasons like this one
[Music]
thailand leads asia in legalizing
medical marijuana next shark
thailand may become first in southeast
asia to allow same-sex unions japan
times oh yes beaches marijuana lgbt
rights thailand seems like the asian
version of california but with a
monarchy and one that is a little bit
easier on the wallet however lately
thailand is in the news for headlines
like this
[Music]
the protests in thailand are making
history for the first time in decades
people are openly defying the authority
of the monarchy al jazeera to give you
an idea of what we're talking about
since july 2020 thousands of thai people
have taken to the streets to ask for a
total change of regime change the
constitution reform the monarchy and
hold free elections fun fact instead of
raising their fist or hand thai people
raised these three fingers and yeah this
is straight out of the hunger games
movie trilogy more about that though
later but let's get back to our story
for just now because trust me when i say
that thai people have no shortage of
reasons to protest we're talking about
one of the most authoritarian countries
in the world
thailand's political system is a hybrid
between absolute monarchy theocracy and
military dictatorship sounds fun right
in fact the thai royal house is the
richest in the world surpassing even the
petro monarchies and it has far more
power than any european monarchy and
you're probably thinking come on grant
if they're so authoritarian how does it
possibly have so much tourism how is it
possible that there are so many digital
nomads who go there to live cities like
bangkok and chiang mai are trendy
destinations for digital nomads which
for those who don't know is people who
work online who could live anywhere in
the world and who choose to live in
thailand and yes thailand can be a
fantastic country for a westerner but if
you are thai you might not think so
thai man faces lengthy jail term for
sarcastic remark about king's dog
telegraph to give you an idea thailand
has the fourth largest prison population
in the world just behind turkmenistan
cuba and of course
the united states and just a side note
here yes the united states has the
largest prison population in the world
but we've already talked about that here
on visualpolitik before the irony of the
freezed country in the world locking up
the most people the point is that
compared to thai prisons those in the
united states look like five-star
resorts and as we'll see later it's very
easy to end up in a thai prison and all
this explains such intense protests as
this one
thailand protests thousands rally for
third straight day despite government
ban bbc however none of this news is
going to attract much attention in
previous visualpolitik videos we have
talked about thai politics and if there
is one thing that characterizes this
country it is the regime changes to give
you an idea since 1932 thailand has
suffered an average of one coup d'etat
every four years regime changes are so
commonplace in this country that they
don't even make the news anymore however
these protests are special and maybe
just maybe this time we will see real
regime change pay attention because
today's video has everything economics
living gods and sex
lots of sex and even a couple of extra
floozies thrown in for good measure so
the question we're asking today are what
makes these protests so significant what
are the protesters asking for what is
the real problem in thailand and why why
have they adopted the hunger games
salute as a form of protest today we're
going to answer all of these questions
but first let's take a look at some
history
[Music]
a divine command this is not the first
time that we've talked about a theocracy
on visualpolitik in many other countries
such as saudi arabia or iran religion
and politics go hand in hand however the
case of thailand goes much further than
that
in this case the thai king is considered
as the direct representation of god on
earth pure and simple in fact the
current king of thailand is known as
rama x ram of the tenth before him there
was rama ix ninth and so on all the way
back to rama the first rama is the name
given after the coronation and is
literally the thai name for the goddess
vishnu
to give you an idea until 1932 thailand
was an absolute monarchy since then
there has been a constitution that
limits the power of the king but even so
the monarch still has a lot of power i
mean at the end of the day he's a god
now however divine they may be thai
kings are moved by very human passions
king rama ix also known by his first
name bohimbal was crowned when he was 23
years old after someone murdered his
older brother rama viii now this all
might sound crazy in and of itself but
wait because you haven't seen anything
yet
[Music]
it would be logical to think that rama
ix also known as lord upon our heads or
lord of life was born in thailand right
after all he is the king of the country
well that would be a big mistake rama ix
was born in cambridge massachusetts
later his family moved to switzerland
where he studied at the university there
so let's take a second just here to
imagine that situation this man who's
living in the west is out with his swiss
friends and they ask him so where are
you going to be when you grew up and he
goes me well i'm going to dedicate
myself to being a deity in thailand come
on lads let's do some shots what's more
after so many years of education in the
west rama the ninth acquired certain
habits specifically he learned to play
jazz
and in fact came to compose his own
pieces
[Music]
but let's get back to our story as you
can imagine if the thai people consider
their king to be a god any offence
against the monarchy is blasphemy or as
they call it crimes of le magest because
this is not a minor issue thailand's les
mages laws are known to be very generic
that is it is not clear what counts as
blasphemy and what does not the only
thing they are clear about is the
penalties which can be up to 15 years in
prison and there are cases that are to
put it mildly totally unreasonable all
the cases i'm going to give you right
now are real examples so pay attention
translating an unauthorized biography of
the king two years in prison insulting
the king's dog on the internet 37 years
in prison throwing black paint over a
portrait of the king 10 years in prison
and hold on because we haven't talked
about the crimes of sedition yet watch
out for the list of things that can land
you in jail in thailand wearing a red
shirt eating sandwiches as a form of
political protest or showing a piece of
paper that says showing papers is not a
crime i repeat these are all real cases
that have put real people in real
presence and of course among these
terrible crimes of sedition is the
salute from the film the hunger games
apparently in 2014 some protesters
started to use it the gesture caught
fire among young people since then
raising three fingers like this
is a crime in thailand
[Music]
and now many of you may be wondering how
it is possible that the thai people have
not risen up against their king before
the monarchy in thailand has existed for
centuries after all well the truth is
that until a few years ago the king of
thailand was a really popular figure
[Music]
to give you an idea more than 12 million
people went to king boomball's funeral
to say goodbye to him and remember that
thailand has 64 million inhabitants that
means that on october the 25th 2017 one
out of every six thai people dropped
what they were doing to go to the grand
palace in bangkok to say goodbye to
their god king
even in cinemas before seeing a movie
thai people have to stand up and listen
to the royal thai anthem and now i know
what you're going to say if the monarchy
is so popular in the country why do they
have so many coups well let's take a
look at that right now
a dictatorship every four years one of
the main advantages of democracy is that
it allows for the change of power
without bloodshed instead of spending
money on weapons for a civil war
candidates spend it on electoral
materials well in the absence of
democracy the opposite is true in
thailand candidates spend as much on
weapons as they do elsewhere on
advertising
[Music]
thailand has suffered 19 coups since
1932. of these 19 12 were successful and
another seven were not all these coup
d'etats follow a similar pattern a
faction of the army organizes the coup
d'etat and it is the king who decides
whether he wants to support it or not
the loser has to go into exile and the
winner becomes the country's dictator
for a few years usually about four i
mean come on they're basically like
elections but only one person has the
vote and that person is the king
[Music]
some of these coups have been really
violent for example in 1973 several
students demonstrated against the
military government of the time 77
students were massacred and 850 were
seriously injured in the protests
that same night the king announced that
the military government had to resign
years later the dictator thanom kitty
catshorn was exiled however other coups
were much more peaceful for example the
1957 coup lasted just a few hours in
this case general sarit thanorat sent
his loyal troops to take over the most
important military facilities he was
supported by a large group of civilians
who were protesting in the streets hours
later this man became thailand's new
prime minister the former leader went
into exile in europe and returned to the
country six years later to become prime
minister again so it seems that in
thailand military dictatorships come and
go but one thing remains and that thing
is the monarchy
and you may be wondering but how can the
people there support this system well
one fairly convincing answer is the
economy with or without a lack of
freedom thailand is one of the richest
countries in the region as a comparison
the gdp or per capita in parity with
purchasing power is around 18 000 that
of the philippines is less than half 8
500 and in china it's 17 000 while many
parts of china still do not have modern
hospitals thailand has public health
[Music]
just to give you an idea while their
vietnamese neighbours were coming out of
the famines in the late 1980s the thais
had the largest automotive and hard
drive factories in the region not to
mention being a real tourist powerhouse
in 2018 they were the 10th most visited
country in the world far above japan or
greece
so how can thailand have such a
relatively developed economy with such a
dreadful political system well mainly
for two reasons its currency the bat is
one of the most stable in the world and
thailand has always had good relations
with the west particularly with japan so
now you'll see so what's changed now
grant why are these protests so
important now well
listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
the middle income trap
in october 2016 the beloved leader king
graham in the 9th died in hospital at
the age of 88.
[Applause]
in a country so dependent on a single
person the death of the king is a time
bomb but in this case the country was on
the verge of approving a new
constitution through a referendum as you
can imagine it was a referendum where
the army told the citizens which way to
vote because
well just because that's what thailand
is like in this case in the absence of a
king the military junta put a senate in
place and announced free elections in
other words as free as they can be in
thailand basically the army would
supervise the process but at least
opposition parties would be able to run
[Music]
[Applause]
and what happens when you allow
opposition political parties to appear
well surprise surprise new opposition
parties emerge for the first time in
decades thailand's parliament had a
democratic opposition party with a major
presence
we are talking about the future forward
party founded by mr thanatorn juwan
gurungaran naket
kur juwan karun kuranikut i'd like to
apologize formally here to all the
people of thailand although let's be
honest i don't think i'm going there
anytime soon anyway this is a formation
that proposes a change in the
constitution that limits the powers of
the king guarantees free elections and
human rights and in the march 2019
elections they got 18 of the vote which
is not bad considering that there are
more than seven major parties that make
up the parliament in fact future forward
was left with a third of the political
power as you can imagine the lord
is one of the most influential leaders
right now in thailand
[Music]
by the way the party's leader is also
known in thailand for being the son of
one of the biggest millionaires in the
country far from working against him
this only reinforced his image being
able to live a life of luxury and
without worries he decided to risk
everything to improve the country and
believe me
the risk is real
his party was banned he faces jail but
thailand's tanatorn drong groom grockett
vows to fight on cnn the news you've
just heard could mean the end of the
future forward party nevertheless many
things have changed in thailand
the first is the economy remember i told
you that thailand was one of the most
prosperous countries in the region well
it's true
it was while all the countries of
southeast asia are growing at a rate of
five or six or seven percent thailand
barely exceeds two percent growth in
economics this has a name the middle
income trap
that is there are many countries that
manage to escape from poverty and reach
what we call average income however they
do not manage to make the leap to being
a wealthy country countries like brazil
colombia and thailand seem to have
stagnated due to this situation if you
remember one of thailand's main
industries is tourism it accounts for
more than 12 percent of the country's
gdp and what is the sector most affected
by the corona virus
exactly tourism after tourism another of
its main industries in this country is
the automotive industry well
check this out
[Music]
general motors to lay off all 1500 plant
workers in thailand following sale of
its factories reuters we're not just
talking about general motors either
triumph the motorcycle manufacturers
have also closed plants in thailand and
many others are threatening to do so
in total car production in thailand has
dropped by 30
in 2020 and its gdp has fallen by more
than 12 all of this translates to
thousands of people being unemployed
however this is not the only thing that
has changed in this country at the
beginning of this video i promised you
sex
and here it is
[Music]
confined with 20 concubines yeah that is
how the current king of thailand has
spent the confinement in a mansion in
germany with 20 concubines and i know
what some of you will say how do you
know that all 20 of these women were
concubines what if they were just his
servants or even as friends well the
truth is that king vader longicorn has
had a long and well-known relationship
with the concubines
thai playboy king anoints lover as his
official concubine the times other kings
would say that they have a collaborator
or a special friend but in thailand they
call things by their name the official
concubine it's as simple as that there
are even videos on wikileaks where you
can see
you can see a lot in fact you can see
everything about this king of course on
visualpolitik we're not interested in
judging everyone's sex life as long as
he isn't breaking any laws this man can
do whatever he wants and believe us he
does now remember that he's not just a
king though he is also rama the tenth
nothing less than a god
you see during his reign the previous
king rama ix had earned the respect of
the thai people in such a conservative
society remember the ninth represented
righteousness and discipline his son is
just the opposite he's been divorced
three times has four illegitimate
children and has appointed his dog as
commander of the air force if all of
this were not enough king rama the 10th
does not even live in thailand in 2016
he bought a mansion in bavaria in
southern germany and wants to rule
thailand from there
[Music]
in fact this is one of his conditions
for approving the 2017 constitution they
had to let him reign from germany and i
know what you're thinking now what if
this king simply doesn't want to reign i
mean that could be the case he wants to
get away from politics and live his own
life but
the reality is quite the opposite
two weeks ago the thai king issued a
royal decree placing two army units
under his direct control rather than
under the normal military hierarchy
world politics review oh yeah that's
right rama the 10th is taking steps to
restore the absolute monarchy in
thailand he's gaining more and more
control over the army in the 2019
elections he banned his sister from
running from prime minister and that's
not the worst thing you see until 2017
the assets of the thai royal house were
managed by the crown property bureau an
institution controlled by the ministry
of finance
to give you an idea these assets
comprise something like a sovereign fund
with investments in local companies for
example the thai royals are the main
shareholders of one of the largest banks
in the country the siam commercial bank
well the first thing that rama the 10th
did as soon as he came to the throne was
to take full control of this office it
is estimated that the institution
controls 40 billion dollars that are now
solely in the hands of the king and it
doesn't end there in addition to that
his salary has been raised from 2021 the
royal thai house will receive more than
1.1 billion dollars from the government
and all this for ruling from his mansion
in germany
in other words thailand has all the
ingredients for a popular revolt
economic malaise a corrupt elite that
has lost the trust of the majority of
his citizens and the leader mr
jung wrong
capable of bringing together all of this
discontent and what might you wonder are
these protesters asking for their main
demands are to put an end to crimes
against the royal leader to force the
crime to be transparent with its assets
and to prohibit the king from
instigating coup d'etats these might
seem like very moderate claims but
remember that we are talking about what
is perhaps the most monarchical country
in the world and that's why it's so
incredible that it's only now that we're
starting to hear things like this
thai protesters call for end of monarchy
on king's birthday deutsche isle keep in
mind that we are not talking about just
one or two protests the demonstrations
in thailand began in february 2020 and
the king's birthday was the end of july
in july 2020 many more people started to
take to the streets in squares and
universities there have been protests in
all of the main cities so far there have
been no deaths but there have been
several attempts by the army and the
police to suppress the protests
however the demonstrators continue to
protest so now the question is over to
you do you think that these protests
will create a real change in thailand
what do you think of the thai monarchy
and of monarchies in general do you
think it's an outdated institution or
perhaps one that still has a place in
our time and will i ever get to go to
thailand leave your answers in the
comments below as always we really hope
you enjoyed this video please hit like
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos also don't forget
to check out our friends at the
reconsider media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
my dulcet tones finally this channel is
possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always
i'll see in the next video if you want
to learn more about politics and world
affairs and hear some more of my lovely
voice come check out the reconsider
podcast where we don't do the thinking
for you find reconsider at
www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple or
google play or your favorite podcatcher
[Music]